- [Narrator] For the past several years,
SpaceX has been developing Starship,
a giant, new deep space rocket
at the company's test
facility in South Texas.
- [Man] Starship heading
back to the landing zone.
- [Narrator] Testing
of Starship prototypes
has resulted in fiery failures.
But last year, Starship
completed its first successful
sub-orbital flight and landing.
Now, SpaceX CEO, Elon Musk,
says 2022 is the year
Starship will face its biggest
test yet, orbital flight.
- I feel, at this point, highly confident
that it will get to orbit this year.
- [Narrator] However, it's possible
that Starship's historic
first orbital flight test
might take place at the Kennedy
Space Center in Florida,
rather than at Starbase
in Boca Chica, Texas.
That's because flight safety regulators
could end up determining
more environmental reviews
are needed for the Texas site.
- An orbital test fight
is a really big milestone
for Starship,
or, really, for any rocket
that's going to space.
- [Narrator] So why after
years of development in Texas
could SpaceX's Starship make
its most important flight
to date in Florida?
And what could that switch
mean for SpaceX's operations
going forward?
On Thursday, February 10th,
SpaceX CEO, Elon Musk,
gave his first update on
the company Starship program
in about two years.
Towering behind him
at the company's South
Texas Starbase was Starship.
- The essential technology,
the holy grail breakthrough that's needed
is a rapid and completely
reusable rocket system.
- When stacked on top
of its massive booster
called Super Heavy, Starship
stands at 120 meters,
or 400 feet, making it the
tallest rocket ever constructed.
- Starship, according to Elon
Musk, is meant to go to Mars.
Starship's rocket system is meant to be
a fully reusable
multi-planetary rocket system.
- [Narrator] NASA selected Starship
as the vehicle to get astronauts
to land on the surface
of the moon by 2025.
And the Pentagon said
it wants to use Starship
to transport military cargo.
But before all that can happen,
Starship needs to be tested in orbit.
- SpaceX has been able to
conduct these shorter flights,
no more than 18 miles up.
But this year, Elon Musk says
he's pretty sure that that
Starship is gonna go to orbit.
- [Narrator] The orbital test
mission still needs sign off
from the FAA, which has been conducting
an environmental assessment
of the company's proposal
to operate Starship in Texas.
- The FAA, of course,
is even looking at this in the first place
because the agency monitors and regulates
space launch facilities,
launches themselves,
and then re-entries.
- [Narrator] Last year,
the FAA held hearings
about the Starship proposal
for the Texas location,
and received around 19,000
comments on the initiative.
- One of the questions with
the FAA's current review
for the proposal for Starship in Taxes is,
are they gonna have to
do additional review
on environmental grounds beyond that?
- [Narrator] In 2021, the
journal reported the Boca Chica
residents said the Starship
project is damaging
to the local wetlands and wildlife.
- They move in and change the whole tone
and tenor of the place,
but they began to do 24/7 construction,
which meant, wall to wall,
people, cars, traffic,
noise, lighting, you name it.
- The agency is considering
the potential impact of using
the vehicles at this site.
Everything from noise
to what it would mean
for surrounding wildlife and wetlands.
- [Narrator] Musk said that if in addition
to its current environmental
assessment, or EA,
the FAA requires SpaceX to
conduct a more in depth EIS,
or environmental impact statement,
of the Starbase site,
SpaceX would consider moving
its orbital test to the
Kennedy Space Center.
In a statement, the FAA wrote,
"Completing the environmental
review does not guarantee
that a vehicle operator license
will be issued to SpaceX."
"The environmental review is just one part
of the FAA commercial
space licensing process.
SpaceX must also meet FAA safety, risk,
and finance responsibility requirements."
- It would obviously set
us back for quite some time
because an EIS takes a
lot longer than an EA.
So we would have to shift out
priorities to Cape Kennedy.
- [Narrator] SpaceX already has permission
to use a launch site at
the Kennedy Space Center
for Starship.
In December, Musk said in a tweet
that SpaceX had started
building an orbital launchpad
for Starship at the Florida location.
- The short answer to if,
is SpaceX abandoning Texas
to shift this program to Florida, is no.
It's possible that the
Starbase site could end up
as SpaceX's kind of long term
sort of research site R&D.
Whereas the operational sort of launchpad
would be in Florida.
They know that they're good to go there,
and in terms of like,
all environmental reviews and analysis.
It's sort of more plug and play.
Whereas Texas, you
still have this question
of what the result of the
current review is gonna be,
and at least the possibility
that there's gonna be
another environmental review beyond that.
- [Narrator] The FAA said
it planned to release
its environmental review on March 28th.
- We don't have a ton of insight into
where I think stand with the FAA.
We have gotten sort of a rough indication
that there may be an approval in March,
but that's all we know.
- [Man] We'll culminate with
landing on the landing pad
in Boca Chica.